vous avec alain cadix peut pas jouer au
foot et un prêt et pleurer vous foot
mais les garçons ils voulaient pas que
je joue ou parce que j'étais une fille
alors du coup je suis parti jouer avec
ma meilleure amie naya où j'ai les
cheveux à celle où j'ai les ongles assez
loin donc pour ça j'ai souvent été
critiqués on a harcelé aussi au collège
un peu traité de [__] on jamais frappé
non plus non l on a déjà essayé moi je
fais du tennis tous les mercredis il ya
trois filles et on est onze
j'ai remarqué que souvent les
professeurs dont que les met aussi à
l'écart elle ils les font jouer ensemble
et s'est personnellement il ya une fille
ça fait un an que je fais du tennis dans
le même cours qu'à elle et j'ai jamais
joué avec elle puisque j'étais une fille
qui pensaient que toutes les filles ne
savait pas jouer au foot et c'était que
dire sinon tu peux pas jouer ou qui sait
pas jouer et tout mais je leur dis mais
quand vous savez ça voyage pas vu jouer
et après je joue avec eux et je vais pas
me vanter mais j'ai quand même un bon
niveau et avril soit un petit peu pas
choquer les prix sont si on la fait pas
du foot en tant que 400 on était
considérée comme une scie et donc du
coup on ne faisait pas partie de la
société pendant une semaine il ya mes
camarades qui m'ont charrié juste parce
que j'avais utilisé du rose pour faire
une peinture
j'étais dans la rue avec ma maman et
j'ai vu un garçon qui était avec un
autre garçon qui était en train de faire
là la course avait quelqu'un y avait une
autre fille qui voulait jouer avec eux à
la poussée du coq
les garçons ont dit non non toi t'as pas
droite a juste le droit de regarder
majorité un gars point man
saison et il est aimé de savez ma et bah
ils ont dit non pour pour jour pour
qu'ils jouent à la poupée mais voulait
jouer permettez ci a qui jouent à la
poupée moi je voulais jouer à vaquer ont
dit non et après minuit si un jour et
bas des garçons i voulaient pas que je
joue un foot
du coup et bah il nous a reculé rocky
les reculs mais et après on héros de
nuit et fait terminé
[Musique]